gronk is back he's in tampa bay if you
haven't heard if you haven't you have
now and draftkings has put out some prop
bets based upon gronkowski's potential
performance and the buccaneers potential
performance in 2020 now that gronk and
tom brady are reunited let's begin with
the buccaneers odds for winning the
super bowl chris they have moved from
plus sixteen hundred which means you'll
win sixteen hundred dollars for every
100 you bet down to plus 1200 so you win
1200 for every 100 you bet they have
plummeted to a certain extent
do you think that that is a smart move
by the odds makers and do you think it's
a smart bet to consider
putting up a hundred to potentially win
1200 on the bucks winning the super bowl
well yeah yeah i think it you know if
you got some extra change to throw
around that you want to hit it big to me
that's one of the places i would look
the tampa bay buccaneers and i you know
i do believe in gronk's ability to sway
that line because i think you know
uh
gronk's ability to stress a defense is
still
very real here you know again i don't
expect it to be the grunk we saw from
four or five years ago but with the way
bruce arians has a creative aggressive
offense and now you add gronk to mike
evans at godwin you know like i was kind
of saying during our show today mike you
know you split gronk out to one side and
now you got evans and godwin on the
other side like holy cow what do you do
as a defense who do you double who do
you send your attention to they're gonna
really put some stress on schemes and
how teams want to approach them now with
this three-headed monster uh you know as
far as weapons for brady
gronk also has an over under for
touchdowns this year at 5.5 he had three
in 2018 but at times he has been a
touchdown machine would you go over or
under five and a half touchdowns for
gronk
oh
that is a good one there i think that
i would probably pick over but just
barely like i don't think it's gonna be
10 or 11 touchdowns i'm expecting like
six or seven i mean that's that's a fair
line there but i think the biggest the
biggest thing he's going to bring to
that football team again when you get
down into the goal line right anytime
they're inside the 10 yard line they
could just block it up oh evans you go
on one side gronk you go on the other
side brady can look at what matchup he
likes better and he can throw it up to
two of the biggest freakiest best catch
radius guys in all of football
yeah i agree with you completely and
look i he's the one guy that tom brady's
going to be familiar with he's going to
be the guy where brady is looking and
and who do you double team right that
that was what brady didn't have last
year in new england there was no one in
that offense that scared the defense
enough to command double coverage all
the time so you're gonna double gronk
you're gonna double mike evans what are
you gonna do about chris godwin it's
gonna be a potential mess for a defense
to try to slow down this offense and we
know how tom brady makes quick decisions
about who's gonna be open get him the
ball and gronk i think gronk will go
over five and a half i i would put the i
would put the over under i'd put it at
six and a half or seven and a half i
think you know he's not coming back to
have a mediocre year he's coming back to
have a big big performance and i think
we're gonna see it that leads to the
final one over under for gronk's
receiving yards this year chris 599.5
over or under
oh
wow
i'm going to go
uh i'm going to say i'm going to last
year 682 is last year right he was
playing i'm going to go over again i am
i'm going to go over and again i don't
think it's going to be by much i think
he's going to be hovering i think that's
a fair number but i think he gets into
the mid 600s once again i think with the
way they're going to throw the ball and
just like we said there's going to be
certain downs and distances where i
think teams are going to favor going hey
let's put the attention on mike evans
gronk is a little older we might be able
to get away with a one-on-one matchup
plus like you said with brady's comfort
zone with him i think when in doubt he's
going to look for gronk so i'm going to
go over there as well
and the other dynamic to remember here
the possibility that they will keep o.j
howard and cameron breit and work gronk
in slowly and keep gronk healthy that
would diminish
the numbers i'm tempted to go under on
this one i think he's going to be a
touchdown machine and maybe you'll see
him in red zone situations but maybe in
the normal
setting between the 20s maybe we will
see him less this year at least until we
get late enough in the season where he
can't get over 600 so i'll go i'll go
over on the touchdowns i'll go under on
the yardage it's a good point though
mike
if you've managed to make it this far
here's a little bit of news that i
picked up right after our show ended he
is done with wrestling for now he is
going to submit to the requirement in
his contract that he cannot pl that he
cannot do anything other than play
football so if you see gronk somewhere
chris pin him and you become the wwe 24
7 champion because he can't fight back
damn i mean i i
i really might i mean if i see him out
in the street i might have to do
something i might have to tell one of my
friends to kneel behind him right
i think that's what i might have to do
one thing that i'll never forget is the
first time that that happened to me now
i'd like to say it only happened once
but when you're going down that first
time you don't have any idea what the
hell's happening when the person's down
on their hands and knees behind you and
you get the little shove i'm surprised
like somebody hasn't cracked their skull
doing that
well they probably have it just hasn't
been anybody famous for us to know about
but uh yeah it still goes on in the nfl
i mean you get out on a grass field and
practice you'll still see some of the
young guys on the football team do that
kind of crap so you always got to have
your head on a swivel on a football
field and when players hear that if they
get back in the training camp and
players hear that you i can guarantee
you they're they're going to have fun
with gronk and they're all going to pin
them and make it a social video moment
and go come on send me my belt and now
the wwb will get some more advertisement
through that so that'll be cool
hopefully that'll be happening in july
and or august because that will also
mean that the world will have returned
to some level of normalcy that those
things can happen time will tell that's
it for today's pft ot we'll be back on
thursday with pft live getting you ready
for the draft chris sims on button
coming up later today plenty of pft pm
content as well thanks for some of your
time and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports